which keep in mind  every other  major industrialized country requires  photo id and many non-industrialized  countries can you vote without a photo  id in mexico nope can you vote without a  photo id in norway nope  finland nicest people in the world nope  el salvador nope and same thing if you  look at a lot of these france nope they  actually require id and a specific  reason for mail-in voting because for  the same reason that elizabeth warren  amy klobuchar jimmy carter bernie  sanders have said that election uh  integrity as our biggest national  security threat  uh is that there would be no way to  track votes it is a serious problem if  you have mass mail in voting that is  where you are more likely to have broken  system errors along with fraud i'm not  saying that the ghost of hugo chavez was  scribbling you know dominion machine  code i'm saying that voting system  anomalies have happened to the tomb of  millions in the country